hey guys this is Eric I'm not streaming
just recording a video for youtube I
wanted to do a quick game analysis of a
game that that took place yesterday in
the chest comm speed chess championships
between Hikaru Nakamura and an Polish
fighter 3000 also known as young
Christoph Duda it was one of the most
spectacular games of at least that I've
seen of this year and there was some
really sensational moves played and
Hikaru went down in in just 19 moves
with white and I do have to give credit
and give a shout out to Robert Haas and
Danny wrench who were doing very
enthusiastic and very emotional
commentary of the whole match but
especially of this game so I'll leave a
link in the video description so people
can check that out but without further
ado let's get into the game and see one
of the most most beautiful masterpieces
of this year so it started off
ironically as a Petrov defense afternoon
I have 3 9 of 6 which doesn't have the
most exciting reputation more
symmetrical more draw reputation and
Nakamura went for a line after Knight
takes d5 d6 you play a pretty rare move
here Knight to d3 which looks very
strange especially for perhaps a casual
viewer where this night just kind of
blocks a bishop it blocks a pawn which
blocks this Bishop doesn't seem like the
most harmonious move the more common
moves are Knight f3 or or night c4 but
after Knight e3 the idea is that after
black regains upon white has Queen e2
forcing Queen e7 and then Knight to f4
and now White has ideas of bringing
light to d5 which is actually a major
threat because the Queen would then be
attacked the pawn would be attacked and
the black queen is always
hi down to defending the night so black
does have to be a little bit careful
here Doudna went for Knight to c6 and
then Nakamura played the move pawn to c3
now I should address what would happen
after Knight to d5 and this position
actually occurred in last year's World
Championship match between Carlsen and
in Caruana a Caruana playing the lock
pieces and at first in this position it
looks like locks in trouble because the
Queen's attacked and wherever you move
the Queen you're either gonna lose the
knight or are the c7 pawn block has a
very nice move here which Carlsen did
play like to d4 counter attacking whites
Queen and what happened in that game is
the Queen's got traded and for a brief
moment
all three Knights ended up on the e-file
as a pretty amusing position and last
year I was actually taking over the u.s.
chess
Twitter feed and I tweeted about this
position which I did dig up the tweets
that it was a party on the e-file for
for the Knights so let's get back to
what happened in the Nakamura do that
game Nakamura played c3 avoiding the
trades keeping more pieces on the board
preparing pawn d4 also preventing the
light from coming into d4 and then play
continued pretty naturally black brought
the knight back white plays d4 Bishop f5
Bishop e3 so avoiding a Queen trade pawn
d5 Knight d2 castling and I think this
is where Nakamura just got a little bit
careless and didn't realize blacks
blacks incredible resource which we're
about to see what should have been
played here is pawn g3 to develop the
bishop and it would have been a lot
better for white to put the King on the
Kings side but what Nakamura chose to do
was Castle queenside and at first this
looks completely okay like even
box bishop is a piercing through the
position it still looks like whites
Kings is pretty safe
however blacks next move was it was
simply stunning and it's not every day
that you get to play a move like this
and I think I'll have the next position
in the thumbnail so that's probably a
spoiler for most viewers but the move
played was Queen to a3 which it first
looks like a complete joke of a move but
if we just look a little bit further
after pawn takes a three black would be
mating with Bishop takes a three very
classic - Bishop checkmates so the queen
is untaken bowl and with the Queen on a
three black has a simple threat of
taking the pawn in e2 but an even more
lethal threat of of mating let's imagine
white just plays place some random move
like h3 if it's better for black not to
take the pawn but to force the sacrifice
of the Queen Queen takes c3 and then
bish at a three mates so with one
incredible move whites whites and Deepti
trouble here
and of course Nakamura realized a danger
and played what was the best fighting
chance in the position went for Queen to
b5 ensuring that black is not mating in
- now if Queen takes c3 and Bishop a3y
can defend with Queen B - but the
position is still very good for black
after Queen B 5 lakhs Knights a to pawn
and okay block has advantage here but it
was still a matter of of converting it
and play continued Bishop to d3 Trey the
bishops takes takes and now Knight to a5
so box really not taking the foots off
the gas when it comes to attacking 985
has a few purposes of course eyeing the
c4 and b3 squares
both of which are accessible on top of
that black also has ideas of lifting the
which which we will see very soon keen
situ here perhaps preparing to play rock
a-one attempting to to trap blacks Queen
do the played Queen a4 check King to be
one and now very calm kind of patient
move from black keen to be AIT's not
really rushing with attack and perhaps
just taking care of the the possibility
of Queen f5 where this would no longer
be check so from this position white
played Knight to f3 and now Duda
proceeds with the rook lift rook to d6
just dreaming of getting the battery
along along the a file Nakamura play
Knight to D to rook a six played and now
the next move from white looked to be a
a very reasonable defensive option Queen
c2 just trying to trade Queens and and
eventually try and survive down a pawn
however Queen c2 is as a final blunder
of the game and I would encourage
viewers if you don't see the the winning
move for black and if you didn't see the
game already feel free to pause the
video and find the knockout blow for
black in this position but yeah the the
knockout blow is yet another Queen
sacrifice Queen a one check telling
Nakamura just just take my queen and not
come or actually just resigned here so
the Queen was never captured but if the
Queen was captured is a very beautiful
maiden to after Knight to b3 double
check the King would be forced back to
be won and now rook to a-1 is game over
now the game itself was was 19 moves so
not every day you can take down the
number one blitz player in the world in
blitz in less than 20 moves with with
not just one but two Queen sacrifices
now I know some people on the YouTube
comments will argue that this is not a
Queen sacrifice the
as black is mating which is true but
sometimes in life I mean you you can
sacrifice something and yet get
something good in return like if I
sacrifice a goat for a trillion dollars
I still sacrificed a goat
it was a really weird analogy I think
I'll leave that in though I think what
I'll do is make a thumbnail for this
video
within the video and then it'll be extra
meta and also I'll show I'll show the
secrets and how to make a nagging mater
style thumbnail shout out to AG and
mater for being a huge inspiration to
everyone so what I want to do I want to
search for thumbnail stuff and now I
have already have a few screenshots of
of my thumbnail stuff couple images of
Nakamura I think I'm gonna use this one
this is a picture I took a a year or two
ago one of the st. Louis I think it was
a sink filled cup Nakamura looks in pain
I don't have any pictures of Duda that
I've taken but I think this will be
suitable for the thumbnail also have the
screenshots of this Queen a3 move so
let's go in let's make the thumbnail in
Photoshop we open up Photoshop oh I was
trying to find the color of the
background earlier let's make a new
thing thumbnail for YouTube is usually
1280 by 720 let's create and let's bring
in the images I'll start with the board
now it's always a question do we put the
board on the left side or the right side
look put it on the right side so the
Queen is centralized in the image just
so people's eyes are drawn to the Queen
the arrow should be should be a nice
leading line not going to be too
perfectionist here but do you want the
board to be as big as possible now let's
bring in Nakamura just drop it in there
and we're gonna size him up make the
face nice and big and we do have to put
him as a lower layer let's make this
even bigger hopefully Nakamura is not
too
disappointed in this photo choice but
you can see the motion like the
combination of Queen III and this
expression tells a very nice story and I
will say during the speech Chess
Championships Nakamura had internet
issues
so his face was not visible during the
time of this game do this face was and
he he did seem to be relatively happy
with himself but we can only imagine
that Nakamura was making a face like
this so anyway I think this will be the
thumbnail I hope you guys enjoyed that
stay tuned for more content and feel
free to comment below what do you think
the best game of 2019 would be was it
this game are there other candidates let
me know in the comments and maybe I'll
do some more game analysis videos like
this so stay tuned I'll see you guys
soon